we remain clear that those who can work
from home should continue to do so
however as those who cannot start to
return to their jobs the safety of the
public and of the transport workers must
be paramount that is why the depart for
Transport has today published two new
pieces of guidance for passengers and
for operators these documents aim to
give passengers the confidence to travel
and they seek to give operators the
information they need to provide safer
services and workplaces for passengers
and for staff we encourage operators to
consider the particular needs of their
customers and workers as they translate
these documents into action mr. Deputy
Speaker the first document is aimed at
passengers I'll summarize some of the
main points contained in this advice
firstly as I mentioned we continue to
ask people to only go to work if they
cannot do their jobs from home that's
because even as Transport begins to
revert to a full service the two meters
distancing rule will only leave
effective capacity for 1 in 10
passengers overall 1 in 10
therefore it's crucial that we protect
our network by minimizing the pressures
placed upon it and assure is ready to
serve those who most need it as a result
we are actively asking those who need to
make journeys to their place of work or
other essential trips to walk or to
cycle wherever possible in order to help
us do more of this last week I announced
an unprecedented 2 billion pound
investment to put walking and cycling
right at the heart of our transport
policy the first stage so earth 250
million will include a series of Swift
emergency measures including pop-up bike
lanes wider pavements and cycling and
bus-only corridors this money should
help protect our public transport
network in the weeks and months ahead
it's my hope that they will eventually
allow us to harness the vast Health
social and environmental benefits
the active forms of travel can provide
the people cannot walk but have access
to a car and I'm appreciate that I will
be the only transport secretary to have
said this for very many years people
have access to a car we urge them to use
the car before they consider public
transport avoiding where possible any
busy times of day I do however recognize
that for some people using transport is
a necessity in this case passengers who
follow the guidance we've set out today
in order to keep themselves safe this
recommends that travelers must maintain
social distancing by staying two metres
apart wherever possible to prevent the
virus we also advise that as a
precautionary measure particularly where
that's not possible people wear face
coverings when using public transport
this could help protect other travelers
from coronavirus where someone has
perhaps unwittingly or unknowingly
develop the illness but they're not
actually showing any symptoms and we
urge passengers to avoid the rush-hour
replan their visits to use contactless
payments where it's all possible and to
wash their hands before and after their
journeys in addition the guidance also
reminds us that at this most challenging
of times it's more vital than ever that
we think about the needs of others our
transport operators their staff doing an
incredible job to keep everyone safe
please follow their advice for stations
to bus interchanges be patient and be
considerate to fellow passengers and
staff in particular we should remember
the needs of disabled passengers and
those with hearing and sight impairments
and older travelers to mr. Dedalus
speaker as I mentioned we're also
publishing a second document guidance
for transport operators today these
organizations really are at the
forefront of the national recovery
effort they know the insides and out of
the needs of their customers the needs
of their workers and they understand
like no one else their industries
specific needs that's why I have no
doubt that operators the best place to
implement the safety processes that work
best for their businesses their
employees and their customers the
guidance were publishing today visors
operators across all forms of private
and public transport on the measures
that they can take to improve safety
these steps include ensuring stations
services and equipment are regularly
cleaned making sure passenger flows are
clearly communicated to try to avoid
crowding to try to keep everyone on
network passengers and staff two metres
apart wherever possible the guidance
will develop over time in line with our
increasing understanding of how korone
virus is spread and indeed how it's
contained in addition it's likely there
will be no one-size-fits-all approach to
this implementation it will need to be
tailored and localised based on plans of
local specific transport needs in
preparation for that process
yesterday I wrote to local authorities
to set out how we can work together to
prepare transport networks at a local
level for restart and ensure Public
Safety
mr. Deputy Speaker the documents I
publish today will help ready our
transport system to support our country
as we seek to control the virus and
restart the economy will inevitably
encounter obstacles along the way as we
embark on the next stage of our national
fight back against this virus and there
is no doubt that we need to continue to
work together to overcome these
challenges and on that note mr. Deputy
Speaker I'd like to express my gratitude
to our partners in the devolved
administration's the local authorities
the mayors trade unions and transport
operators for their work over the past
few weeks I look forward to the
continued collaboration in future
because cooperation is going to be key
to set in the country on the road to
recovery if everyone plays their part if
we continue to stay alert we can control
the virus and save lives and if we all
follow this guidance or making essential
journeys I believe that together we can
harness the power of Transport to build
and renew a revitalized nation and I
commend this statement to us